like greta tunberg our next two guests
rather are among the young
environmentalists who are making a
difference a big difference julianna
bradley and georgia wright created the
inherited podcast
to share stories from the youth climate
movement here's a clip
some people brush climate off as a
future problem i don't blame folks who
do this
sometimes i even do this this crisis is
a painful thing to contemplate
my chest tightens just talking about it
but for people in my generation
being able to talk about climate change
isn't really negotiable anymore
we are running out of time we're feeling
the urgency
and we can't shut up about it and we
don't really want you to shut up juliana
bradley and georgia wright join us now
good morning to you both guys really
good to see you
i love the podcast it's so well done
it's so well done you guys are such
badass as what you're doing out there
but one of you i think it was you
georgia juliana your dad said look you
need to start
you need to stop talking about this or
else you're not going to be invited to
parties
whose dad said that it was actually the
father of jenna depaldo one of one of
our
interviewees so and one of the activists
that we featured it was her father
and then then but i loved it to be fair
we've both been told that
many times that's what i've heard and
your response is what because you said
listen
we want to leave this world a better
place than what we inherited because
what we inherited
is a flawed place so what is your
response to people who just
don't get it giuliana you go first
please
sure well i think something that drew us
one to the name inherited them but also
to the youth movement
is that this is nothing new every single
generation of young people
is born into a world that they didn't
create that was
handed to them and often is asked okay
do something with it or deal with the
consequences
and more often than not generations say
well no we're not going to do that
we're going to leave it behind better
we're also going to live in a world
currently while we're living
that's better so i think when when
people
say like why
like why would you stand up to something
that is and that is you're not going to
do anything
um to actually solve they've done it
before too they were born into a world
that had things that were solved
and they now get to live with the the
world that
has progressed beyond that so um our
generation climate is one of our biggest
burdens that we've inherited but then
georgia there's a thinking that you guys
are overreacting
i mean i i simply think that that's just
not the case
this is the future that we have in our
hands right now and
quite frankly we are extremely pressed
for time so
you know every moment that we have makes
a huge difference
and so it's the actions that young
people are taking right now
that are making the difference and
making a future and i think as far as
the pessimism goes
it's it's really a misconception that
young people are pessimistic and that
we're party poopers if we
are being told not to bring up climate
change at parties because actually
you know we are having a lot of hope
for the future that we want a good
future that we're willing to fight for
it
i think it shows a lot of really a will
to live and an excitement for
for surviving and enjoying the life that
we do have um so i actually think
it's it's really a positive thing it's a
total misconception that
youth climate activists are all doom and
gloom because actually i think we have a
lot of hope otherwise
we wouldn't be fighting georgia you
discussed climate anxiety in the podcast
and we heard juliana mention her feeling
her chest tighten
when she when she talks about this what
do you mean exactly climate anxiety
uh i am one of many many many young
people who all experience
climate anxiety which is the feeling of
uncertainty over a livable future it's
the uncertainty i feel when i think
about
starting a family when i think about
what the world's going to look like you
know when people tell me to put money in
a retirement fund i'm like
i guess but you know what if what what's
going to be what's going to what's the
world going to look like at that point
you know it's hard to understand um our
future in the same way that previous
generations have understood their future
because our future does not feel
nearly as secure and so climate anxiety
is that physical reaction we get
and i've experienced that quite a lot uh
the tightness in the chest the
the feeling in the stomach the feeling
of doom and dread and and
panic that i think a lot of young people
feel when they contemplate a world that
might be shifting beyond our control
yeah
but it's balanced by hope i think we
need to point out and part of the
anxiety
is that it's not in your control from a
leadership point of view
the perspective of people under the age
of 40 is not the perspective of people
let's say over the age of 50.
and that creates a certain impasse yeah
you said you're sick of being called
young and naive that is not the case
here thank you both georgia wright and
juliana bradley
we're really glad you joined us this
morning